ah I make this look good
oh great the Winter Soldier
for a guy named Knuckles you are really
bad at punching surrender the compass
you're a no match for me I've been
training for this my entire life and I
have no training at all yet here I am
ahead of you that's gotta be
embarrassing
[Music]
my rings
has anyone ever told you you've got
serious anger issues you mock me with
your weak jokes but you know nothing
about me Hedgehog well I know you
echidnas have a habit of showing up
uninvited and ruining my life ruining
your life another bad joke I lost
everything because of you my tribe was
on the verge of its greatest Victory the
last of the owl Warriors had been
located soon long claude's Emerald
Secrets would be ours but my father
stopped me from joining the fight he
said my moment to honor our tribe would
come but it was not this moment those
were the last words he spoke to me I
never saw him again
we both lost everything that day
goodbye Sonic
are you okay yesiva
no no it wasn't a trick
Tails take the compass and get out of
here
[Music]
oh
later haters
tails
tails come on wake up
Joe's helping the fox over pursuing the
compass yeah of course he did new
friends same pathetic weakness
oh no no no no okay we're in real
trouble here come on Tails I need you to
fly us out of here time to wake up
see you kids enjoy the fresh powder